[La musica] ha
bisogno di una città
la bobina è come si dice "nessuno zoo zoo zoo
zoo lì sembri Baker con
Mike dritto sempre lo stesso vecchio rosso e
venderò tutti nello stesso modo è la
mattina che siamo venuti l'abbiamo fatto per una
città di provincia buona  buongiorno
buongiorno Monsieur e dove siete tutti
oggi
des bookshop posso finire la
storia più meravigliosa di aver perseguitato un
orco ora che non è carino
non stare zitto guarda che stanno insieme
quella ragazza sta provando ad andare a ovest
Karen sono stati  distratto non si può
dire poco da Kalpana cloud per la
testa in su su qualche nuvola non nego che è
una ragazza divertente che beh c'è qualcosa di
dolce e quasi gentile ma era cattivo
aveva freddo e io sto bene io sono qualsiasi cosa e
così insicuro  Non saprò cosa non hai
visto lì prima di
[Musica]
Jana è stata più vecchia - e poi possono essere
[Music]
stati amici malvagi lì, quindi soldi
inaspettatamente solo un piccolo cambiamento a
dir poco vai con il piccolo spavento
né  una Bella Addormentata Andy sempre
e solo
sempre una sorpresa come prima pure mamma
appena l'alba